bon comme c'est mon dernier jour chez
toi ou je me suis dit que quand même
j'avais vu log est un petit peu cette
journée avec mon retour à paris pour
vous faire voir rouge était durant une
semaine et c'est la maison le wifi
fonctionne est le moins bien au monde
toutes les vidéos de la semaine j'ai dû
les télécharger en 4g depuis le
téléphone
j'ai donc cramer tout mon forfait 4g en
fait en quelques jours et c'est pour ça
que j'ai pas beaucoup répondu aux
commentaires non plus là vous
reconnaissez sais où j'ai fait la vidéo
avec tao ici c'est son espace bureau là
vous avez une partie de ses accessoires
de magic est ce qu'il y a dans la valise
d'un magicien aulas l'a tous fait revoir
ce sont des grandes illusions ou alors
ce mec ça vous fait vraiment des soirées
chou avec mais c'est possible ça peut
servir aux deux d'ailleurs l'un
n'empêche pas l'autre
et si vous avez l'atelier de madame k o
de la femme de tao
voilà ça c'est pour le sous-sol et
maintenant je vais prendre mon café
si je ne prends pas de café je veux je
veux je vais abandonner tout toute cette
vidéo mais non c'est le gros boudin qui
arrive c'est le groupe dias va être bien
réveillé
allez y les régions je fais la bise à
ils ont bouché le jeu de cartes de tarot
ont sauvé les trois quarts pour ceux qui
se posent la question budail à un an il
a un an et demi un an et demi donc il
est bientôt au bond et consommer et les
mois et dit qu'il a trois mois
il a des pattes énorme lui qui goûta le
seul problème c'est qu'il est persuadé
d'être tout petit tout petit et tout
fragile et du coup c'est un espèce
d'hippopotames nouveau départ et puis on
a le droit au petit pipi du matin qui
fait plaisir quand vous amuser avec des
chiens sans se fatiguer de monstration
de tao
quand vous êtes vieux qu'on n'a pas le
temps de finir en phosphore attention
lumière le petit couple après boulin
burgeat il sait pourquoi il court mais
lui qui donc est à mes temps et dans le
haut de la maison d'un chambre de tao
évidemment parce qu'en fait c'est à eau
qui tient la chaîne studio balti
s'acheter et on va bosser sur son
spectacle durant ces quelques jours on a
essayé d'écrire tout une structure au
spectacle de tao de trouver un thème à
l'univers et là on est en train de
dépiauter ce numéro on regarde tous les
numéros qu'il a et qu'il a il a tourné
un petit peu en vidéo on est en train de
les analyser droit cérébraux vous pouvez
de rechange et des trucs là on a pris
comme thème le portugal bonbons qu'on
soit bien d'accord on arrête les clichés
les vietnamiens ne mange pas de chien ce
sont les chinois qui vont ça on voit les
vietnamiens monde et leveaux scopus et
même si je suis chez tao erreur il faut
quand même que je montre la vidéo
donc c'est parti pour une heure et demie
deux montages du mental bleus pour cette
dernière journée antoine nous a prévu
une bonne surprise
on va manger typique on va manger local
on va chercher un hack j'ai peur j'ai
peur parmi vous
les familles partout famille de tao
rachète tout en fait bientôt limoges
s'appellera littoraux et parce qu'à
limoges quand tu joues un kebab il faut
prendre la voiture
je suis je suis
jia
c'est bon tu as rangé le bipper ce bon
repas
ce bon repas équilibré qu'on fait avec
antoine coca kebab
car oui tao s'appelle antoine j'aimerais
mail et avait rétabli en japonais toi
caméras partout c'est cool je prenais le
bus ce qu'elle voulait pas dit mais les
racistes des japonais c'est un chien
moutons tu as un mélange de chiens on
compare pas boulba boudeulle je loue et
voilà au final j'aurais passé sept jours
chez gétaz aux aurores et andrea bien
sûr et je suis en train de préparer mec
bagages pour aller prendre le train on
va le train si j'en ai un puisque pour
l'instant le train que j'avais réservé a
été annulé merci les grèves et la fallu
que je choisisse la couche est
supérieure ou inférieure
ça c'est un vieux réflexe de colo 2 je
veux le lit en hausse il ya des lits
superposés
mais on ne sait pas pourquoi on fait
l'idiot on veut le l'idiot donc j'ai
pris le lit du haut et s'il ya des
couchettes
est-ce qu'on m'oblige à dormir du coup
durant le trajet ou est ce que c'est un
peu libre je ne sais pas je vais le
découvrir les migrations
oui
ce sont environ
il y avait bien des couchés dans le
train que j'ai pris alors j'ai pas osé
filmée parce qu'on était quatre et c'est
assez ça c'est serré diront de foot donc
je n'osais pas trop film et je pense que
je serais passé pour un ouf durant tout
le trajet merci d'avoir regardé ce blog
petite information je vous ai mis un
message sur facebook twitter un star et
snap ce matin pour savoir qui voulait
faire une vidéo avec moi demain pouces
avec le mardi je mentalise quelqu'un là
j'ai vu pas grand monde cette semaine
puisque j'étais chez tao donc ce soir à
21h je fais un skype avec l'un ou l'une
d'entre vous allez voir sur facebook je
vous explique comment ça se passe je
fais le tirage au sort à 20h30
n'oubliez pas avant de partir également
de laisser un petit pouce en l'air du
lundi qui va faire plaisir pour toute la
semaine et comme le mental blog c'est
une vidéo par jour rendez vous demain à
17h ciao